[Music]
boston
is with us in charleston that sounds
confusing hey boston what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can i help
so i recently just graduated college in
may 2020
i'm 22 years old and i was really
fortunate my dad had the 911 gi bill
so my first three years of college were
absolutely free or paid for out of
pocket
by my parents wow wonderful yeah i'm
extremely lucky what's your degree my
dad always promised me
that he would pay for my college tuition
and that last year we had to take out 40
grand from my last out-of-state year
who's weak i had a um i could you that
the thing i took it out in my
name under my credit score because my
dad had a worse credit score than me
so it's technically out under my name
and my dad
has sorry little nurse my dad has
automated monthly payments so he is
paying it off
but should i just also pay that off
because it's under my name or should i
take this
blessing and i have no other debt and
should i start
like snowball investing
what's your degree in computer science
okay and how much you're making 70 000 a
year
okay good for you well done thank you so
much
um
uh your dad is a great guy and i'm
really thankful for his
um service
and how that afforded you the first
three years of school
uh for free and i'm also thankful for
his willingness to do the other things
however he has no money
right i mean no no is that is that a
correct statement he has
no money no that's incorrect he makes
nearly a quarter million a year
he makes a quarter of a million a year
yes his military pension is eighty
percent why is he broken
i mean he got a divorce three years ago
we moved every two years
sometimes he purchased houses and
thought they were good and you still
live with your dad
no i just graduated college i mean so
there's no way
so there's no we we used to
now they but if he makes 250 000 a year
i would ask him to if he wants to honor
this
process i would ask him to pay it off
this year
not over 20 years
because it leaves you vulnerable
yes it does i mean i mean i am preparing
in the instance that i have to take over
it
it doesn't seem like that day will come
because
now listen that's not that's not the
point if he's not going to pay it off
in six to 12 months which he should do
my god
boston something's something's in your
soul about this deal why
why are you even asking this question do
you not feel right taking the money now
no um it's not that i wouldn't accept it
i'm just
curious if now that it falls under my
name and i know we don't care about
credit scores here
but yeah i care about i care about you
having a student
loan debt of 40 000 your dad doesn't
have any debt
and you do you're not asking a math
problem you're asking a character for
a question
yeah i just wish it would be paid off
sooner amen
so if he's not going to pay it off in
six to 12 months
after you have this discussion with him
tonight then you should
okay and that will be an unclaimed
my retirement uh 10 contribution my rock
contribution yeah okay
yeah you you're in baby step two dude
you have forty thousand dollars in debt
yeah with your name on it right yeah and
it's gonna be an uncomfortable
conversation and it's gonna be a
grown-up conversation and you're
you're because your dad's dad you're
making 250 000 if you can take care of
this within six to 12 months
fine if you can't i'm going to knock it
out
okay or i say i should say won't
not can't because he can yeah
if you want i don't want this hanging
over my head it's in my name
i've become increasingly uncomfortable
with that dad and so i
i get it if something else is going on
but i'm just going to tell you if you
won't knock it out
with your 250 000 income in six to 12
months then i'm going to
because i don't want this over my head
yeah that's that makes sense that's not
disrespectful
it's not mean you're not wagging a
finger at him you're not throwing guilt
trips around
you're not calling up and going you
should really do this because you said
you would you're not doing any of that
you're just going to go dad you make
plenty of money i know what your income
is
and i know you've been through some hard
times in the past but here we are today
i am feeling stressed and uncomfortable
this weight of forty thousand dollars
across the top of my trapezoids and i
can feel it on my back
and i if you won't get rid of it in six
to 12 months i'm going to
and if he says no just go do it go do it
and don't hold him accountable don't
give him the side eye at christmas yeah
just forget it he had a plan
you're choosing to accelerate that plan
which i think is the right thing to do
yeah and then go do it
and here for future reference okay uh
and this will help you with uh with
other conversations that will come up
another time that because
i've had to learn this the hard way is
that um
good people with good intentions who
handle money poorly
never have any money and therefore
always put themselves in a position to
not keep their word
and it's weird but i mean like like i
know this guy he's a good man
and just let him move in your rental
house and he'll pay the rent no he won't
because he's never paid rent on time in
his freaking life you know so why am i
gonna
all of a sudden reinvent this guy in my
mind just because
he's a good guy you know and the weird
thing is he can actually be a good guy
but suck at handling money
right i was that guy i was telling he
was a good guy but i sucked at it
you know and therefore it left me not
being a good guy sometimes you know
because i couldn't keep my word because
i didn't have enough money to keep my
word
and i know people who make 250 grand a
year
who run out of money before the month is
over every single month
i mean any put any number up there i can
find somebody that spends more than they
make i mean they all
i just act like they live in congress or
something i mean my god
so you just spend it like it's water but
you know and it's out of control
disorganized chaotic and so the point is
don't th the lesson to be learned for
you in the future sir
and for all of us in the future is if
there's a pattern in someone's life
and you ignore that and
and ask them and accept their promise
then that's on you
right and when you sign your name to it
assume you're paying it back
yeah assume you're paying it back and if
money comes in the mail then
that's not right and again that's not to
chide you boston you didn't do anything
wrong you're 22 years old you're trying
to figure this stuff out man
you're stud for even calling and putting
this stuff forward
so thank you for doing that but the the
thing is
i quit expecting you know this guy
said people change but not much you know
that's not true they do transform people
do change they can't you have the
ability and the power
you know i can do all things through
christ who strengthens me i can change
if i choose to step into it and change
right
but uh but but if somebody's got a
pattern of doing something
and just because you like them you don't
want that pattern to be there
it's still there it's not going to just
magically go away yeah and i had to
learn that because it bit me so many
times like
this guy's broke he has no money he's
disorganized he doesn't pay his bills on
time
but he promised me that's right
and that's what i do and he just he's
turned it around let's let's see what i
do he promised me
yeah it's um it doesn't work that way
you have to get yourself
almost like our last debt-free screamer
said you know we had to get to where we
got sick and tired of not being able to
control the
uncontrollables the variables when
pandemic knocks on your door and huffs
and puffs and wants to blow your house
down
which it will yep when whatever it is
the the
what was the other you know the uh uh
child uh custody battle right knocks on
the door
uh when infertility knocks on your door
when cancer knocks on your door car
wrecks knock on your door layoffs knock
on your door
when 2008 knocks on your door when 9-1-1
knocks on your door
when black monday 1987 knocks on your
door
i went when september 23rd 1988 when i
filed bankruptcy knocks on my door
you know are you ready when the big bad
wolf huffs and he puffs are you ready be
the third pig
say never again never again this is your
never again year
2020 is not good for much of anything
but it's a great never again year it's a
great line in the sand that's a great
never again year